[Music]
I'm doing great after last night
especially yeah everyone watching will
have no effing idea who you are so we
should just start with that
all right cool I'm Cameron I'm from
Funko's marketing department I lead our
social team and the social team consists
of you and one person me and a team of
five others and is our podcast or social
channels video content email marketing
all sorts of things yeah oh wow yeah at
Collider we have like I was gonna make a
joke but like yeah you have a real
depart hey when I started it was me and
one other person so I feel you building
so I want to jump in right off the bat I
went to your Funko Friday fun day what's
a co fun days yeah every fret but it is
every Friday of sdcc right so how long
okay I've never experienced a party like
this in my life so I want to give a huge
thank you to the people that invited me
I don't want to name-drop to get them in
trouble but um I've never experienced
anything like this it was pandemonium
and crazy and more energy it was like
being in Hall H but like a thousand
people yeah it was insane so the thing I
learned was that I guess the event sells
out in like 10 seconds yeah so we will
hype it up and say you know in a week
we'll release tickets and then people
just camp out and wait for a time and
you know it's it's wait wait so where do
you people get tickets they will get it
so we will release them on our on
Eventbrite we go through Eventbrite so
we'll say like you know this you know
Wednesday at 10 o'clock they're gonna go
just make sure you're you know aware
when they go they go in like two seconds
and then we have a waitlist I think
Brian said of like 30,000 people so yeah
insane it's so fun right now is it like
have you guys and this is really getting
into the weeds but like one of the
things that I found is that there's a
lot of like BOTS and a lot of programs
that can help you basically cut lines
yeah how do you fight that when you have
such a demand well we set a password so
you actually have to wait for us to post
the password - then get in - then have
the ability to buy two tickets so that
slows people down and authenticates that
they're real okay so that password is
basically everything yes right and we
don't actually know the password until
about ten seconds before we decide it
and then we post it got it so basically
you decide on the password then you
enter it in the system and then we say
go
there's really there's not really a way
to cheat it as far as we know okay
that's actually good because then we
also go through the process of going
name by name of who did get a ticket to
make sure there are I mean there are a
lot of returning customers a lot of
people that we know I mean it's very
community-oriented people that we see at
conventions throughout the year it's
tedious but it's worth it completely so
if I'm not mistaken it's like 1,600
people it's about that yeah and each
year we add a couple couple hundred more
and it's funny to think it started about
20 years ago with a I don't know a
couple dozen people and it was I think
it was like a cereal themed science fun
days it was like very low-key but it was
for the hardcore fans so we try to
highlight that every year yeah the thing
that I learned last night was there's a
lot of what I learned
Goodin because I went they give you you
get a lot of cool stuff yes there's like
a poster tube filled with some very
limited figures yes then they all
through the night they do these like
drops where they play this crazy song
that is addictive as hell like I forget
the party what surprise patron fries but
yeah and then they just do these mystery
drops where you get like a limited pop
yeah but I thought the coolest thing was
everyone who goes gets to get a
prototype yes and that that was
something that we did this year as a new
thing that's in it in the past few years
it's gone through a kind of a shift
there was a point in time where we were
just throwing them off stage it yeah so
we were like we'll put them in you know
black plastic bags so you don't know
what they are and then people will be it
was not okay so we were like let's
regulate this let's have people come in
get their drink tickets go to a photo op
get their proto sit down I think you
know like actually enjoy themselves and
so it is we found a way to actually get
those exclusives to people in a safe way
and in a way where it's randomized
completely because I'm yeah there was a
machine not a machine there's people
behind it you stick a coin in like a
chip yeah yeah it was interesting yeah
we it's it I mean fun days as a whole is
kind of a living breathing thing and
it's run entirely by Mike Beck or the
founder of Funko and he he really brings
it to life and he's thinking a lot about
the fan experience and what he wants
people to take away from it
so also you had mark hamill there last
night oh my god yes that was amazing
right my thing is the thing that I found
interesting was there was like I mean
it's really random who gets some of
these limited ones but he has like two
numbers and those people got a limited
fungo that was like a teammate yes which
is crazy
we tried that for the first time last
year we had a an 80s prom themed fun
days and so we tied in stranger things
we actually had hopper from stranger
things come out and he did the same
thing and picked two tables and they got
gold hopper pops so it's a cool new
tradition right the thing that I have
found and I'm not an expert at this and
I don't want to pretend that I am but
they're very collectible yeah so sort of
as a company how do you sort of deal
with that in the whole collectability
aspect and making sure that you know
what I mean like let's get them yeah or
is it sort of like you're just blessed
with that people really want them and
there's only so much you can do well I
think a way to combat that is you saw
the boxes of fun with the Freddy's and
the Freddy Funko pops in them we
actually last year also started to make
variants that we sold online so at the
same time as the show starting we
dropped a box of fun you could buy
online so we're helping people it's kind
of like a shared exclusive that we'll do
with the retail or and at a convention
so we're trying new things all the time
but but to your point I mean it is
highly collectible for a reason we
respect that but that's why we kind of
go for the shared exclusives I noticed
on one of the ones that I got was like
limited to I want to say 350 or 500 yeah
very low number yeah is that how often
do you guys do that where it's like
really low numbers is it just at
comic-con typically yeah it's usually
comic-con sometimes on our Funko shop
we'll do release each week and sometimes
it's around five hundred to a thousand
but typically yeah it's usually
comic-con and especially SDCC yeah there
definitely seemed to be it was crazy
yeah it really was crazy last night and
the energy and what you know and I did
get the sense of community yeah in the
room and everyone seems to know each
other totally you know it's like it was
it was it was a really interesting crazy
experience that I'm very lucky to have
been a part of and I hope the other
thanks for having well thank you for
coming and thank you for sharing it
in that wakes I think people see there's
exclusive things it's really cool to go
but really the community is why we're
doing it right I'm also you guys were
really cool I did that Russo brothers
panel yes I've made these pins then say
I'm a fan of the Russo brothers you
could get in the room so a big thank you
to that yeah I know that was a big push
for you guys is here his pins yes
where'd that whole thing come from well
so we decided to do something special
for SDC C's 50th year by doing 50
exclusive pins you could only get at the
show throughout the whole convention to
highlight our licensing and retail
partners and panels that tie into Funko
as well so that was kind of a special
thing that came in last minute but thank
you for you know allowing us to do the
Russo brothers button I think that was a
really special way for us to commemorate
something that was I would say the
cultural moment of the year so far so
you know that was really cool should
also see I don't know if you saw it if
you were in the room or not but they
they're team animated the button I heard
all I saw was the button on the giant
hall age screen I was like wow you know
they animated the button and they wink
wink I'm gonna remind me after this and
I'll try to get you guys the file oh I
would love to see it like when I saw it
it was like that's great I want to talk
about the piss yes
on your left so what exactly is this so
if you went to fun days yesterday it was
freaky Tiki themed so it was all you
know floral shirts leis all sorts of
stuff like that the story of the show
was the explorer Marco beckon Werth the
third yeah what's better right here he
was on on this quest for the golden
Freddy Idol which was the big giveaway
at the end of the show so everybody in
the room got the pop version but we made
a pop pin version that we're launching
to start off our pop pin series which is
coming later this year so it's actually
coming in a pop sized box it's the size
of a pop it's got a detachable stand on
the back so you can actually display it
out of box you can take the stand off
and wear it and we've got more coming
later this year so you could get this
wait so is is this limited or this is
limited you can get it through our
social media channels for giving it away
we're giving it away at the throughout
the convention today in tomorrow so it's
a special commemorative event
we couldn't actually do anything before
before fun days because it gives away
the whole final giveaway if we did it on
Friday or before but yeah it's we got
this this great a freaky Tiki golden
pretty Idol pop pin let's jump into the
stride as you get I feel like I'm
pimping out your product no no that's a
drum I'm curious so what this is how
often is this the first strategy game so
yeah we we acquired a gay a board game
company earlier this year for Spurs on
and we're we're working with them to
create Funko versus the strategy game
it's for players who just want to play
with a couple of their friends it's for
long time strategy players you know it's
it's we have Harry Potter we have Rick
and Morty Golden Girls Batman they're
all coming out at the same time you
their expansion packs and booster packs
so you can actually play with this you
get another one you can actually combine
the two and the characters can interact
so you could yes please there's booster
packs yes
are they packed the way like wizard
collectables makes limited cards or it's
not really like that it's not limited
we're not really focusing on limit a bit
limited edition right now we're just
trying to get players to get into the
game but they are playable on their own
so you don't need this and an expansion
to play the game you could just get the
expansion and play that on its own the
figures that are in there yes they're
actually smaller than a regular pop so
it's a new scale for us and we're gonna
be we're gonna be at Gen Con next in a
couple weeks we'll be launching Funko
verse there there will be some for sale
we'll have a couple of other surprises
as well and we'll just be demoing the
game for a bunch of folks so the figures
that are in there are it's like a wide
release there's no limited nature it's
not like they're limited to 5,000 you
know what I mean yeah yeah I know that
these are gonna be widely available
there may be exclusives down the line
there may not be we're still trying to
determine but right now we want people
to play you know we want it to be fun
and what's cool is they actually have
accessories that they can drop and other
players can pick up so if you ever
wanted to see you know Blanche from
Golden Girls with the Batarang this is
the way you can do it I also noticed
that at your booth this year which is
way bigger than you've done in the past
yeah you have like 70 exclusives yeah I
want to say that I could be wrong about
this no it's it's up there um
uh how do you keep on it's crazy how
many pops you guys have made yeah is it
have you guys reached a point where it's
actually like a struggle to find
interesting ones that you like really
want to make it's you know it's
interesting because we're reflecting pop
culture we like to talk about being fast
fashion pop culture collectible so we do
pay homage to the long-standing
collectibles we also have an SD CC and
Funko booth and for the first time we're
SD CC licensed out there to can mascot
so we made that as a pop me that as a
pop Pez
we've got pop figures coming for you
know we have the the Sith trooper the
for Star Wars we've got brick and Morty
that aligned with their announcement of
the characters during sdcc so really I
mean we we won't run out as long as pop
culture remains fun you know I know that
there's a few that are only at the booth
and then there's a lot of retail partner
exclusive right how does that work so
the ones that are at the booth that a
retail partner exclusives is that like a
variant at your booth or how does that
whole thing work so if it's a shared
exclusive it will be at our booth and
the shared retailer whether it's online
or in-store the difference is the ones
in the convention center have the same
sticker the ones that are at the shared
retail online or store have a different
one it says convention exclusive so that
that's really it is the same figure yeah
literally sticker now how many do you
have a ton of fans that because I spoke
to somebody who works at your booth that
I know and he was telling me that there
are people who come up and literally buy
one of everything yes oh yeah if you
because there's a lottery to just get
into the booth to then buy so it's and
that's I mean that's new as well I mean
we're always playing around process but
yeah as soon as people can get and they
just buy one of everything how do you
carry 70 pops from that well we have
enormous blue bags so how many can one
bag hold um I did one earlier and I
think it was about well there it varies
because we have six-inch pops and I'm
sure things as well but you can
basically get all those exclusives in
two of those bags shut up yeah
70 70 there's huge yeah okay I did not
think that was yeah I'm gonna I'm
stumped well the bag is actually
probably the most valuable exclusive in
the booth honestly it's amazing
yeah it's it's underrated I'll say got
it yeah okay
there's also I think a few that are
limited just to the booth yes so we I
think we have two this year and it is
the otter pops pop figure we're
launching the rest of them later this
year but we have the Louie
blue-raspberry otter pop and then we
also have the Wynonna herb pop and on
something like those yeah how do you
release the numbers I do yeah on that
and it's also printed on the sticker
okay so how many did you make of those
two yeah a thousand each okay so it's
okay got it so it's similar to look what
goes on at the Funko party right where
it's like pretty limited right yeah
exactly and we do a lot stock for each
day so we aren't running out on the
first day or anything like that
completely I actually want to get back
to the prototype thing let's do it I
have some friends at have some
prototypes I actually have some Star
Wars prototypes oh I love very nice I
love those things because they're
obviously very unique mm-hmm so you have
a thousand or 1500 people that attend
the event last night right like are
people getting double like typically at
Funko yeah how many prototypes do you
make of one of those pops
so that's a really great question it
varies depending on the type of figure
and we there's actually two types of
prototypes you can get to there's the
all-white and then there's the one that
has color call-outs for different pieces
sure in the pop design so it varies in
number typically there's at least one
color version and one white version for
each one so it's possible that there
were two of the same proto there but
they wouldn't have been the same color
right okay so you're saying on a
manufacturing level you think there's
really only one of each color there
there is at least that there could be
more there's usually not more than one
or two of each really I know that with a
lot of toy manufacturers what happens is
that they will I mean they could create
four to ten a prototype and then what's
interesting is a lot of toy
manufacturers say this is the the thing
that you're making right they will
create this with like a different
colored box of different color cardboard
to just see what it looks like as a
mock-up yeah do you get a lot of that or
it's pretty much the mock-up of the box
doesn't really exist the packaging is
different and I think it's easier for us
to manufacture it's more of just like it
we get so far down line
before it even gets molded that it's you
know they sketch out the design they
actually render it in 3d sculpting and
then that has to be checked off before
we can even make it so by the time we're
manufacturing it pretty much
everything's signed off got it so so
basically the okay I now understand why
people went crazy for the prototype yeah
this is really there's like you're
saying to me there's really not like ten
of each no I mean they're in the history
of pop figures there are some that might
have around that but it's unusual yeah
yeah you're asking a lot of really good
questions about prototypes I mean we get
questions like how can I get one how
valuable are they
but really the process is you know it's
it's just a production sample and then
what's what's so interesting is our
artists as artists are like well but we
made the final product don't you want
that they're like yeah but I mean this
is kind of cool too one of the things
that I think you've already touched on
and when we've talked about is you make
a lot of limited figures right and these
are like the as limited I mean this is
the extreme limited yeah oh yeah this is
like next-level yeah you know I don't
know the first thing about I don't want
to open that door but I was gonna say I
think it's actually I think it's really
cool yeah that the company gives out
those prototypes because I think it's
actually just really really cool a lot
of a lot of toy companies won't do it
yeah you know what I mean well and
that's the focus on the community too
because a lot of fun days essentially
started because of the the community
around Funko and I think when Mike and
when Brian are thinking about ways to
give back
it's those are those are the fans that
are just rabid for Funko information
anything to do with it like people will
ask to buy our staff shirts after the
show because it's a collectible so I
mean if they're they get a piece of the
production that went into an actual pop
figure I mean they they go crazy okay
really special they at the end of the
show Brian went through a whole slide
thing Brian Jesse yeah yeah showing off
all this upcoming stuff he sure did what
is what are you most excited about as a
company in terms of maybe some of the
pops that are coming up or some of the
cool [ __ ] that you guys are doing that
yeah sorry for the language now that you
guys are getting ready to push out
besides what's on the table yeah
absolutely I mean we're really excited
about bringing our own IP out to market
so we have web more forest which is a
new it's new in that we
have more of a focus on it with
children's books t-shirts figures plush
that setting at Barnes & Noble and we
have a big push for that later this year
I'm sure you saw some of the pop towns
stuff so we're really starting to do
more with our own IP and also bringing
in a nice mixture of you know what
people are kind of expecting you know
the episode nines of the world but then
also the other things that maybe you're
not totally expecting at the same time
so I really like the product mix and the
licensing that we're working on right
now have you guys talked about and I
could be completely wrong but have you
guys do you guys do t-shirts or posters
or is that stuff that has been done yeah
we do apparel we have pop tees we've
been doing that for a couple of years
and we is it like limited stuff or is
it's not usually limited sometimes they
are and they'll be bundled with a figure
or a PEZ or something like that but it's
typically just a box in its own
packaging that resembles a pop box sure
what's the biggest pop with vehicle or
animal or whatever that you guys have
made and what is is there anything
coming up that you know in the back of
your brain that's like oh fans are gonna
this is massive well I do know that
we're gonna have more of a focus on add
icons which our fans seem to just
absolutely love so you know all the
cereal mascots things like that they I
mean toucan sam people love that so we
have more add icons coming out and then
in terms of big for like pop rides and
vehicles and things like that I clear I
honestly don't know I mean a lot of our
product announcement is up in the air
until maybe they are two before before
and then that's when marketing really
pushes it out got it I think I'm gonna
stop there and just say thank you so
much for coming by and I really did
learn a lot about Funko last night way
more than I ever knew so I mean it
sincerely thank you for having me and
hopefully in the future Collider and
Funko will do something interesting
let's do it that would be awesome
yeah I'm dropping that it's gonna happen
to be continued right exactly thank you
so much thank you